today the Matt wall show an outraged
media calls for a hockey player to be
punished and fined for refusing to dress
up in rainbow colors to celebrate gay
pride it's not enough to tolerate
anymore or even celebrate you must
participate also Alec Baldwin has
finally been charged with a crime over a
year after killing a woman on a movie
set plus Al Gore warns that the oceans
are boiling away is that true we'll fact
check in our daily cancellation I
announced the birth of my twins last
week and this was somehow a source of
outrage outrage for many people on the
internet we'll talk about all that and
more today on the Matt Walsh
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
the current administration's New Year's
goals are to tax spend and turn a blind
eye to inflation if this is at odds with
your goals then and if you're tired of
the government playing games with your
savings and your retirement plan then
you need to get in touch with the
experts at Birch gold today for over 5
000 years gold has withstood inflation
geopolitical turmoil and stock market
crashes now you can own gold in a tax
shelter retirement account Birch gold
makes it easy to convert an IRA or 401K
into an IRA and precious metals text
Walsh to 98 98 98 to claim your free
info kit on gold and you can talk to one
of their precious metals experts with an
A plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau thousands of happy customers and
countless five-star reviews you can
trust Birch gold to help protect your
savings text Wall Street 98 98 98 and
protect yourself with gold today that's
Walsh to 98 98 98 today
welcome to the show as you know I've
been gone for the past several days as
we welcome two new children into the
world it's a joyous time in my family
even though my wife and I have both
slept a combined three and a half hours
since last Friday so if I start
hallucinating during the course of the
show today don't be alarmed it's just a
bit of mild psychosis caused by sleep
deprivation nothing to be concerned
about the most important thing is that
uh both babies and my wife are healthy
and recovering well I am also recovering
well for the record though admittedly I
wasn't a very active participant in the
actual birth uh but anyway we thank all
of you for your prayers and well wishes
now
let's talk about
um hockey and I confess that I know
almost nothing about the sport um I'd
always thought of it as sort of like
soccer on ice and involving athletes who
won't collapse to the ground writhing in
pain at the slightest hint of physical
contact so hockey is colder than soccer
and tougher and manlier
um and you get to punch people
so like slightly less boring that's been
my general impression of hockey from a
distance
and it may have been a generally
accurate impression for a long time
until wokeness got a hold of the sport
as it has with every professional sport
and began to destroy it as it has with
every professional sport and everything
else in society and these days
apparently
the most basic qualification for anyone
who wants to be a professional hockey
player the first prerequisite is not
that he's tough or talented on the ice
but that he shows sufficient fealty to
the new state religion of the United
States of gay so Philadelphia Flyers
defenseman Yvonne provorov uh sparked
intense backlash this week after
declining to participate in the team's
Pride night festivities
the daily wire reports Philadelphia
Flyers defenseman Yvonne pavorov refused
to take the ice during warm-ups to
observe Pride night on Tuesday citing
his uh Christian faith provorov uh chose
not to participate in the team promotion
intended to show support for the lgbtq
plus Community the pregame skate
included players wearing Pride themed
jerseys that displayed their names and
numbers in rainbow colors and holding
hockey sticks wrapped in rainbow colored
tape before the Flyers home game against
the Anaheim Ducks
rainbow jerseys
rainbow uh numbers
rainbow hockey sticks
one wonders if they're actually really
getting the message across enough I mean
this seems a little bit too subtle to me
can they dye the ice a rainbow color can
they sprinkle rainbow confetti from the
roof
can they set off rainbow fireworks
outside the building and inside the
building
can they give mandatory rainbow tattoos
to every player and fan in attendance
and summarily execute anyone who refuses
perhaps these are some ideas that they
can they can take advantage of for
future Pride nights this week they went
with the bare minimum merely asking
every player to Adorn themselves in a
flag meant to express pride in the
sexual behavior and lifestyle choices of
LGBT people
but this one player refused and after
the game he explained his reasoning to a
deeply offended media here he is
everybody I respect everybody's choices
my choice is to stay true to myself and
my religion
that's all I'm gonna say
any like I said that's all I'm going to
comment on that if you have any hockey
questions I would like I would answer
those
questions
for us
Russian Orthodox so pravarov uh cites
his religious beliefs as a reason to
decline participation in Pride night
he's asked which religion he belongs to
and rather than responding by saying
something like none of your business you
god-awful parasite which would have been
you know he would have been perfectly
justified in responding that way he
instead answers and says that he's
Russian Orthodox now this is obviously
a very good and very valid reason to say
no to Pride night
but
any reason would have been just as good
okay we should be really clear about
this he could have just said that he
didn't wear the rainbow uniform because
he thinks the colors are ugly or because
he just didn't feel like it or because
he finds it absolutely bizarre and
deranged that he's being asked to
express pride in other people's sexual
preferences
he could have said I don't even know
what it means to express pride in
someone else's sexual preferences I that
emotion doesn't even like make sense to
me I don't know what you mean
you could have said that
literally any reason would be valid
because there is no valid reason for a
team to ask a player to participate in
this kind of stunt in the first place
it's bizarre enough that gay people have
their own flag and I mean having your
own flag for sexual orientations of
course not just one flag is many
that's bizarre enough
marching around announcing your
sexuality to the world is also bizarre
enough but it's absolutely psychotic
that people who are not gay would be
expected to participate in this kind of
charade
the point is that proverov doesn't owe
an explanation to anyone
much less does he have to actually tell
them what his religion is
what needs to be explained and defended
but can't be is the existence of Pride
night in the first place
but that's not how the media sees the
situation of course to them his refusal
to Adorn himself with the rainbow flag
is an unspeakable Act of apostasy so
sports writer Marcus Hayes over at the
Philadelphia Inquirer along with many
other media personalities he's echoing
you know the sentiments of so many
he demanded that the player be benched
for this infraction Hayes wrote in his
column quote let's not complicate the
issue pravarov refused to warm up
Tuesday night against Anaheim because he
does not support the right of lgbtq plus
people to even exist he cites his
Devotion to the Russian Orthodox Church
in his in his eyes their life is a sin
about that
patriarch Creole the church's leader in
Russia and reportedly a former KGB agent
in May Justified Russia's invasion of
Ukraine because Ukraine allows gay pride
parades and if Russia and other
homophobic states do not oppress lgbtq
plus persons that human civilization
will end there
this is homophobia at its most extreme
if you subscribe to this belief you are
a homophobe a little Rainbow tape on
pravarov's hockey stick wasn't going to
send into hell so yes if the Flyers were
staunch in their advocacy pravarov
should have been benched
from its hockey is for everyone
initiative to hosting a transgender and
non-binary hockey tournament the NHL has
spent millions of dollars in the past
decade to erase its image as a
non-inclusive racist homophobic business
that prefers straight white players to
entertain a straight white audience the
Flyers have been leaders in this
initiative and they shined all day and
night Tuesday in addition to the warm-up
jerseys the team held a pre-game skate
for lgbtq plus youth provided
complimentary tickets for members of
nine lgbtq plus organizations to attend
the game and hosted a meet and greet
with players and then pravara pravarov's
refusal came from his dedication to an
oppressive religion
apparently
I like the Apparently at the end so he
he makes all of these wild assertions
that are not grounded in reality at all
and at the very end he says apparently
as if that it makes it okay
yes let's not complicate the issue says
Haze what's not complicate it by being
reasonable sane adults when instead we
could be you know we could we could
engage in spittle flecked half drunk
temper tantrums which are then somehow
published in the newspaper
but Hayes's perspective appears to be
shared by the majority of the hockey
media and others who work around and in
the sport uh here's a very brief
sampling of a couple of tweets Matt I
don't know any of these people are but
apparently they work you know in the
hockey world
Matt Larkin tweeted this is on the
Flyers as much as it's on proverov one
host Pride night two learn of a player
whose religion preaches hate toward the
community supported by Pride night three
learned that that player rejects Pride
night four let him play on Pride night
what a slap in the face
Aaron Ambrose wrote let me get this
straight you have a player that openly
declines to participate in an inclusive
Initiative for a community I am proud to
be a part of and you still dress him in
the game be better NHL Flyers
Charlie O'Connor says the whole point of
a team wearing Pride jerseys is to send
a unified message that lgbtq people
people who like the Flyers are seen and
welcomed
that the team supports them and has
their back pravarov made it abundantly
clear that he didn't want to see or
welcome that group of fans
meanwhile on the NHL Network an analyst
said that if prabharav is a Russian
Orthodox and he doesn't want to take
part in a pride parade then he should
just go back to Russia
and Ivan program can get on a plane any
day he wants and go back to a place
where he feels more comfortable take
less money and get on with his life that
way if it's that problematic for him and
he's been in North America for a long
time he played in the Western Hockey
League he's now been in Philadelphia for
many years if this is that much of a
problem for him to maybe assimilate into
his group of teammates and in the
community and here in this country
that's okay listen you can feel any way
you want but the beauty is if it bothers
you that much
there's always a chance to leave go back
where you feel more comfortable I
understand there's a conflict of shorts
going on over there maybe get involved
so
go back where you came from is now a
perfectly acceptable response not
xenophobic at all apparently provided
you're speaking to a white man and the
sin the white man committed is that he
isn't gay enough but then you can say
that but only a white man by the way if
this was uh uh you know if this was a
player from Uganda so let me I don't
know probably aren't a lot of hockey
players from Uganda if this was you know
basketball player from Uganda or
something and it was a similar situation
um
I can guarantee you that that dude that
doofus would not be on TV saying if you
don't like it why don't you go back to
Uganda
but it's okay because he's from Russia
originally so you can say that elsewhere
uh in media another Sports journalist
was I mean he was practically in tears
of this issue and he was in this and
this rant goes on for like three minutes
uh we'll only play just a quick sample
of it here it is
the theme from the National Hockey
League is hockey is for everyone okay
the theme is not hockey is for everyone
dot dot dot unless you don't believe in
gay rights then do whatever you want
if the National Hockey League's going to
do this if any league is going to do
this do it properly
or reevaluate what you're doing
because there's not a lot of
repercussions and I'm seeing
from any League now it could change with
the NHL
could change with the NHL I think you
find the Flyers a million dollars for
this I'm not kidding
figure this out and stop offending
people on nights where it's not about
that it's supposed to be about
inclusivity
the National Hockey League need to
attack this and figure this out
because what I heard last night was
offensive
and didn't make any sense because for
instance if that was a military night
okay right if anyone in Canada or in the
States on a military appreciation night
wouldn't wear a jersey pregame do you
have any idea the Uproar that would have
happened on that
well I'm glad you brought that up
because I do have something I do I do
actually have an idea of the response
and we know that if someone didn't show
appreciation for the military or you
know didn't want to show appreciation
for the United States didn't want to
didn't want to be patriotic these very
same people in the media would be
defending and celebrating that person as
a hero and we know this for a fact
because that's exactly what happened of
course with Colin Kaepernick the only
difference is that the military
fights for our country which means they
fight for all of us provided the
military is being properly utilized and
not being sent overseas to fight battles
that have nothing to do with us but I
mean that's the subject for another day
the point is that when we show
appreciation for the military
what we're doing is we're showing
appreciation for the service
that it provides to the country
notwithstanding the way that the
military is abused by the bureaucrats
um so that's the idea of the military
right
well what service has the LGBT cult
provided
what what are we supposed to be
appreciative of
Appreciation Night for LGBT why why
should I appreciate them
what what have they ever done for me or
for you or for anyone
what exactly has the LGBT Club what have
they done for the country
what service are they providing what are
we thanking them for again
I mean I'm asking the question if you're
saying it well I gotta have appreciation
okay for what
I mean I'm sure I'm look I am perfectly
I believe in gratitude I believe I think
gratitude is a is an underrated virtue
so I if you're telling me you should be
grateful for this person or this group
great tell me why
you should be grateful for LGBT people
okay
because
we're thanking them for having sex with
each other that's I mean that's what
we're supposed to appreciate
that's what you want Yvonne pravarov to
be proud of
what you want him to be proud of that
again what does that mean for example if
you're if you're a heterosexual and
you're expressing gay pride what you're
proud of
someone else's sexual activity
it doesn't make sense
to start with
oh but it's not about that they say it's
about showing respect
if you don't wear the pride flag you
don't respect gay people all right then
cool so then if you don't wear a
crucifix and Proclaim Jesus Christ your
lord and savior
uh you don't respect Christians
indeed if you don't actively engage in
demonstrative acts of Christian worship
you not only don't respect Christians
but you don't think we have a right to
exist
your refusal to wear a cross around your
neck is a statement that you want all
Christians killed in a genocide
is that how this works now
if you're not actively participating in
some groups uh event then you hate them
that's how it works evidently but only
for the LGBT cult
it's been given pride of place hey place
and you know it's a special case
because LGBT is indeed the state
religion
and the state religion demands
participation remember this is the
process we talked about this before
this is the trajectory for all things
where the left is involved
it always goes this way first you're
made to tolerate
and then you're made to celebrate
and then you're made to participate
first you must merely you know uh put up
with
some even if you object to it you're
supposed to just put up with it and not
say anything and not object
um you know acquiescence basically
and that's the first step
and then as soon as they get everyone on
board with that they say well no that's
not enough you also have to applaud we
need you to really actually applaud
and then even after you're applauding
they say no no we need you out there you
need to be in the game okay participate
you have to involve yourself in what
they're doing
and with the LGBT call we have long
since reached this third stage of
participation involvement
that's that we are way past you'll be
made to care now it's you'll be made to
part to be a participant in
and that was inevitable ever since we
started on the first stage
just put up with don't say anything
don't object don't express your own
viewpoints
we should have said no back then
some of us did but not enough so we
better start saying it now
now let's get to our five headlines
if you own a business you know the past
few years have been a bumpy ride to put
it mildly from coveted lockdowns to bite
inflation you could probably use a break
and Innovation refunds can help if your
business has five or more employees and
managed to survive covet you can be
eligible to receive a payroll tax rebate
of up to twenty six thousand dollars per
employee this is not a loan there's no
payback it's a refund of your taxes the
challenge is getting your hands on it
how do you cut through the red tape and
get your business the refund money well
you got to go to getrefunds.com their
team of tax attorneys are highly trained
in this little-known payroll tax refund
program have already returned one
billion dollars to businesses and they
can help you too they do all the work no
charge up front and they simply share a
percentage of the cash that they get for
you businesses of all types can qualify
including those who took PPP non-profits
and even those that had increases in
sales also can qualify so just go to
getrefunds.com click on qualify me and
answer a few questions this payroll tax
refund is only available for a limited
amount of time don't miss out go to
getrefunds.com get funds.com
well I know I already said this I just
want to uh say again if you'll forgive
me for being
sappy and sincere for a moment thank you
to everyone who's been uh praying for my
family for my wife and the babies and I
know there are a lot of you out there
keeping us in your prayers and I'm very
grateful for it and I'm not going to get
into a lot of details but I will say
that your prayers ended up being as
prayers always are but in this case
especially important even more than I
anticipated because the delivery was uh
complicated they had to do an emergency
C-section to get the second baby to
deliver the second baby
um and not an ideal scenario when you
got to go into a C-section in the middle
of a delivery of twins
um so quite a scary situation for
several moments there but fortunately
everything worked out okay as mentioned
the babies are healthy my wife is
healthy and recovering
and the babies are also I'm I'm um
pleased to say quite uh opinionated like
their old man they they take after me
they've enjoyed sharing their opinions
with us
um in the form of crying quite a bit
very much like adult leftists you know
newborn infants and adult leftists that
tend to communicate in similar ways and
the first night back from the hospital
you know the babies took turns sharing
their opinions with us all night
um wanting one would cry and then fall
asleep and then and then the other would
take a shift so there's a kind of a
shift there's like a divide and
conquering thing where they said okay
now it's your turn and they were just
passing the Baton back and forth the
entire night uh divide and conquer it's
a it's a method we're obviously familiar
with this being our second set of twins
but there's an added twist now
um of trying to keep track
of which baby is which because our first
set were fraternal and these are
identical
so this has been a very fun wrinkle
um and especially late at night when
you're sleep deprived it's dark and
you're like wait which which baby is
this again and I've suggested you know
there's like different problems
different different solutions to the
problem of how do you keep keep the kids
apart when they're identical identical
twins and by the way
identical I don't know if you knew this
because this game is a little bit of
surprise to me uh identical twin means
like they're they're literally identical
they actually look exactly the same I I
it's it's
I guess I knew that but then it's
different when you actually have kids
and like we were examining we're looking
at the way they're you know even things
like how their ears are shaped and can
we see a difference there no 100 the
same which is pretty amazing
um so
we've had different ideas for uh keeping
everything keeping keeping track where I
think one solution that I had suggested
was well what if we just give them the
same name
and then there's no way and then it
doesn't matter there's no way to get to
whatever name we use we know it's the
right one
so that was look it's just a brainstorm
is all you're throwing ideas out there
now admittedly when you are sleep
deprived in the middle night babies are
crying it's not always the best
brainstorming
uh environment I will admit but that
idea was shot down frowned upon by the
family and probably be frowned upon by
Society so I'm sure we'll we'll uh
figure it out as we and we just have to
deal with the fact that this is
something that the twins as they get
older
The Identical thing I'm quite sure
they're going to be exploiting that to
no end I I would if I was them I mean I
couldn't blame them
all right
let's begin with this this is uh hot off
the presses I just saw this uh Story
come across my desk in that I just it
popped up on on Twitter actually so this
is the headline from The Wall Street
Journal Alec Baldwin to be charged with
involuntary manslaughter in the rust
shooting
I'm just reading this now for the first
time it says prosecutors plan to charge
Alec Baldwin was involuntary
manslaughter in the fatal shooting of a
cinematographer on the set of the movie
rust in New Mexico in 2021 the district
attorney in Santa Fe said on Thursday
the film's armor overseeing weapons
Hannah Gutierrez read will also be
charged with involuntary manslaughter in
the incident according to a statement
from Santa Fe area district attorney uh
Mary karmic altwise the charges are
expected to be followed by the end of
the month
and that's not all the film's first
assistant director David Halls has
agreed to plead guilty to the charge of
negligent use of deadly weapon
um according to the statement
and of course the shooting occurred on
the set of the low budget Western
outside Santa Fe New Mexico in October
2021
so it's been well over a year during
preparations for seeing Mr Baldwin
discharged a live round from the
revolver killing 42 year old Helena
Hutchins the films director Joe uh Joel
suzo was wounded
and in New Mexico involuntary
manslaughter is a fourth degree felony
that carries a maximum incentives of 18
months in prison
which is absurd by only 18 months in
prison
that's the maximum my God
the maximum for killing someone the most
you could expect to get is a year and a
half in prison
and we know for for with near certainty
that Alec Baldwin will not be he
probably will not spend a day in prison
with him I guess he's going to plead
down and
get probation or something like that
um the fact that they even
you know it took them a year over a year
almost a year and a half to even decide
to charge him
we can we can be pretty sure that if any
one of us were in a similar situation it
would not have taken that long
and we'd probably be facing steeper
charges than that
and I say this as someone who
yeah
I'm not even as like there are there are
some people who want to fully throw the
book at Alec Baldwin and give them like
first degree murder charges and I've
never advocated that because I because I
do think that the blame here is it's not
just Alec Baldwin I do think he
obviously shares the blame with other
people on the set
and your hand at a gun and someone says
apparently what happened they handed the
gun they said it was a cold gun uh
meaning that it's not loaded with a live
round
and he was handed and he was told that
now he's still supposed to check it
especially before pulling the trigger
but you share the blame I think a
manslaughter charge makes sense but 18
months in prison has a maximum for
killing someone isn't
completely absurd
especially because again we know that
he's not actually going to most likely
uh serve that time
all right
daily wire headline
Al Gore goes on unhinged climate rant
condemns detainment of Greta thunberg
former former vice president Al Gore
ranted about climate change during the
world economic Forum in Davos
Switzerland and condemned the purported
detainment of activist Greta thunberg of
course that detainment was entirely uh
enact and that was all fake anyway it
was all a pageant which is all that
Greta thumberg ever does the former
Democratic presidential candidate said
in in passion Jeremiah that the
conference that carbon emissions are
raising the temperatures of the
troposphere the part of the atmosphere
that contains oxygen to an unsustainable
degree he claimed that increased
emissions are linked to extreme weather
events and the apparent boiling of the
oceans
we have that clip let's listen to that
when are we going to bring these
emissions down and and just to put the
science in a slightly different context
people are familiar with that Thin Blue
Line that the astronauts bring back in
their pictures from space that's the
that's the part of the atmosphere that
has oxygen the troposphere uh and it's
only five to seven kilometers thick
that's what we're using as an open sewer
if you could drive a car straight up in
the air at interstate highway speeds you
get to the top of that blue line in five
minutes and all the greenhouse gas
pollution would be below you we're still
putting 162 million tons into it every
single day and the accumulated amount is
now trapping as much extra heat as would
be released by 600
000 Hiroshima class atomic bombs
exploding every single day on the earth
that's what's boiling the oceans
creating these atmospheric rivers and
the rain bombs and sucking the moisture
out of the land and creating the
droughts and melting the ice and raising
the sea level and causing these waves of
climate refugees predicted to reach 1
billion in this Century look at the
xenophobia and political authoritarian
trends that have come from just a few
million refugees what about a billion we
would lose our capacity for
self-governance on this world we have to
act so in answer to your question I
would say we have to have a sense of
urgency much greater than we have yet
had and we need have had and we need to
make some changes
yeah the oceans are boiling I don't know
if you knew that uh I didn't know that I
didn't know the oceans are boiling
because that's um what's the word for
insane that's an insane claim to make
the oceans are not boiling just so you
know just you know by the way in order
for the oceans to boil
uh you would need we would need an
average temperature on Earth of um
I guess 212 degrees probably a little
bit more than that actually because I
think the boiling point for point for
salt water is is slightly higher so it
would need to be we need to be over 200
degrees before we get to the point we
got to worry about the oceans boiling
and uh of course if if we got anywhere
near that temperature then the oceans
boiling would somehow actually be the
the least of our concerns because we all
in fact we'd already already be dead
most life on Earth would be dead uh if
we got anywhere near that average
temperature
and you hear things like that and you
might want to assume well if you don't
if you really don't know any better you
haven't been paying attention at all
you might hear that and say well he's
being metaphorical or this is like
Poetic license hyperbole
um
no none of this is is meant to be seen
as hyperbole or as metaphor or making a
vivid illustration this is all supposed
to be taken literally and so when they
say that he's not the first person to
make this claim about boiling oceans you
are supposed to actually imagine in your
mind the Pacific Ocean looking like a
tea kettle a giant tea kettle that's
what you're supposed to imagine
and we often say about these people
Al Gore and all the grethunderberg and
all the rest of them
that they're that this is that these are
doomsday prophets and it's very similar
in a lot of ways uh this is part of the
modern day you know the the the new
American state religion
and so in many religions have their own
doomsday prophets this is this is this
these are ours our doomsday profits
um and there are
a lot of interesting similarities
between these doomsday prophets and the
Doomsday prophets of old especially the
ones that were more directly religious
um all the various Doomsday cults that
have
popped up over over the years especially
modern society
and one of the
one of the through lines here one of the
similarities with a with these doomsday
people is that they make these
predictions
the world's going to end at this point
because this and this are going to
happen like here's what's going to
happen and this is how we'll know the
world's about to end and then it will
end
and they make these prophecies and these
predictions and they don't come to pass
well the Doomsday Prophet never admits
that and says oh my gosh I was wrong
about that thank God I was wrong about
that turns out we're okay they never do
that
all they do is just change you know they
move the goal post
um
and in increasingly absurd ways there
was that uh I forget the name of the
Doomsday Prophet 10 years ago or so
who said that there was going to be a
rap He gave an actual date for The
Rapture he said on this date there's
going to be a Rapture and you're going
to see people floating up into heaven
and if you're left behind you're screwed
and then the day came and uh nobody was
floating and so then the goal post was
moved and he said oh it was a spiritual
Rapture so you didn't see it was
invisible it was an invisible rapture
and you thought what does that means I
mean there's some people their souls
left up to heaven but their bodies are
still walking around
well the climate change alarm is to a
very similar thing keep moving the goal
posts now all that said so that that you
know we we say that they're doomsday
profits like a religion religious
doomsday cult thing
uh and it is that
but it's also not just that there's
something even more sinister
um brimming below all of this
which that this is
you know an anti-human conspiracy
there's a reason why they're saying all
of this and why they want you to believe
that the oceans are boiling and that uh
we're all on the verge of
Global destruction
it's because they want to make you
afraid so they can control you
which is a tale as old as time from
tyrants they make you afraid and then
they exploit the fear we saw the same
thing with covid we see the same thing
with the tyrants who run our uh our
civilization
in many different you know
manifestations
but
this is a this is really a a global
conspiracy among governments across the
world
and uh
to make us terrified that the end is
nigh
so that we will
surrender
you know control over our everyday lives
which is what makes things like I don't
mean to bring the gas stove discourse
back
but it's what makes
things like the ass stove important
because that's no small thing
and if it is small it's it's the fact
that it's small that makes it
significant
because that is the that is how detailed
they want to be in their control over
our lives like every aspect even the way
that you
the the tool that you use in your house
to boil water to make pasta they want to
control that too they want control over
that
and if they want to control those little
smaller things then uh then certainly
it's the the bigger things they want to
control most of all
line from the daily
one gay couple allegedly pimped out and
made child porn with adopted children
this is a very difficult story to read
it's
one of the most horrifying
news stories
I've ever seen
but here is the the story anyway a
shocking investigation has reportedly
uncovered disturbing new details about a
gay activist couple in Georgia who are
charged with raping their adopted sons
and pimping them out to a local lgbtq
pedophile ring
a month-long Town Hall Town Hall
investigation published Tuesday viewed
recorded Jailhouse calls and new court
documents and spoke exclusively to a
family member revealing that the alleged
sexual abuse went much deeper than
previously reported the investigation
will have three more installments
according to town hall the married
couple William Dale zulock Jr 33 is a
government worker his husband Zachary
Jacoby zulak 35 a banker
were arrested last summer on charges of
sodomizing their two Elementary age sons
and prostituting the children
they were indicted by a grand jury on
charges of incest aggravated sodomy
aggravated child molestation felony
sexual exploitation of children and
felony prostitution of a minor if
convicted they faced more than nine life
sentences each both men have pleaded not
guilty
um
let me get into some of the details the
zoo locks adopted the brothers now 9-11
from a Christian special needs adoption
agency
before they arrest the couple lived in
affluent life in Oxford Georgia and
Atlanta suburb the children were
enrolled in third and fourth grade when
their um
adoptive fathers were arrested according
to a 17 count indictment the two men
allegedly performed oral sex on both
their adoptive Sons forced the boys to
perform oral sex on them
they raped their sons anally at least
once the older boy was allegedly injured
from
the rape
the sexual abuse allegedly began in late
2019 and began became worse in 2021
Williams has since admitted to forcing
his 11 year old son to perform oral
copulation on him
David he admitted this
I can't even keep reading this uh
it's an important report from town hall
and you can go and you can and this is
as I said there are multiple
installments of it uh and and it it's
it's good that town hall is following
the story
the daily wire is following it
because we know that this is the kind of
story that uh the corporate media is not
interested in uh they
uh
this is not something they want to talk
about
especially when you I mean it's bad
enough for their narrative anyway uh
that the culprits here are is a gay
couple but then also when you when you
add in this LGBT pedophile ring
um that just makes it all the more
certain that the corporate media is not
going to want to talk about this
what can we say about it well to begin
with public execution for both should be
the the penalty uh I just think every
time I read
someone who does something horrific like
this and then they get charged with
multiple life sentences
every time I read that it
it makes me Furious
not only because of what they've done of
course but just the the absurdity this
charade of giving malt what the hell who
multiple life sentences
as if that's supposed to oh no now we're
really serious life in prison isn't
enough so we all acknowledge that life
in prison isn't enough for these demons
and so we're not just gonna give him
light prison we're gonna give them nine
lives in prison well if they were cats
then maybe that would mean something but
they're human beings and so they only
have one life to live and you're not
making the sentence any harsher by
adding on life sentences it's totally
symbolic and I think it's a it's a it's
a grotesque just mockery of Justice
because what they should be doing if you
are admitting
if the justice system the court system
is admitting that a life sentence is not
enough of a punishment which it isn't
then there's only one other step up and
it's not to add on well if we'll give
them not we'll give them 50 life
sentences that'll show them
no if the one life sentence is not
enough of a punishment and we all seem
to agree that it's not
then the next step is execution
um
and it should be done publicly and it
should be done pretty quickly
charge them you can victim they're
convicted uh you you take them out you
take them out back shortly thereafter
you parade them out you pray them out in
front of a crowd
you want a crowd there
because we want them to know that this
final disgrace of them being killed we
want them to know that it's being seen
we want them to know that
we want them to have that additional bit
of suffering
we want all the we want all the
suffering for them possible we want to
cause them immense suffering
because that's Justice
and we also want Society to see that we
want Society to see this is how we this
is what we do with people who treat kids
this way
anyone else in the LGBT pedophile ring
when we find you this is what we're
going to do to you
so that's what it should be
first of all
and the second point is that this is not
uh surprising this is horrifying it's
infuriating it's evil it's uh nauseating
it's disgusting it's a lot of things
um
but it's not surprising
you're putting children into a
disordered environment
and when you do that you can't be
surprised
by the horrible things that follow
look children need a mom and a dad
that's what children need they need a
mom and a dad children every child has a
mom and a dad
um every child biologically has a mother
and father not every child has a mother
and father who are willing to are able
to care for them
for whatever reason
and so does that mean that we say well
uh
you know your first your first your
biological set of mother and father
didn't work out so we're just gonna so
that whole arrangement we don't you
don't need that
we need to do something else for you no
we'll give you two dads or two moms or
one mom or whatever you know I would say
it's fine you'll settle you'll settle
for something else
uh
that cannot be the solution
now yes is it if you
can mother father couples can they abuse
their children does that happen of
course it does
but you want to give kids the best
chance possible
you want to put them in the most ideal
possible situation to start with
and horrific things will still happen
even when you do that we all know that
that's one of the that's just that's one
of the terrible things about living in a
fallen world but you still want to give
kids the best chance possible
which means you give them a mother and a
father
and by the way you know and I made this
point on on Twitter and uh there were
people pretending as always
to be offended by it
um and yet as always you know I say this
and most other people they listen it's
like they know that I'm right even if
they won't say it out loud and um the
point is that I would not
I would I would not hire a man
to babysit my kids for two hours so that
my wife and I can go out for dinner I
would never do that now
if there's a man who's a close family
member a close friend who I who I know
very well and Trust
it's obviously different
but I would not hire when it comes to
like hiring a babysitter
someone you don't really know and you're
hiring someone this is what they do for
a job and you're bringing them in to
watch your kids I wouldn't hire a man
for that
and almost no parent would or ever has
so they could hear that and say oh
that's I I don't well no almost no
parent would
you know you go on some babysitter
service and you you know you're looking
for a nanny service or whatever it is uh
and there's a lot of them out there
and you're looking for someone to care
for your kids uh if you see a man's
profile come up you're scrolling right
past that one almost everyone does
because again it's about it's about
putting your kid in any situation in the
most ideal possible situation
you're playing the odds you're looking
at statistics
and so
you know almost no one would hire a male
babysitter to babysit their kids
and yet we're we're giving male couples
kids to adopt
does that make sense
like would you have hired these two guys
to come watch your kids for a night if
you were on let's say you're on a you
know baby nanny service or something
someone's recommended to you maybe
so oh you need a babysitter and you say
who you got and then they named these
two 30 year old men
would you like would you say okay y'all
haven't come babysit my kids for three
hours
almost nobody would
but they admitted out loud or not
and yet we're giving or adopting kids
out to them
all right let's get to the comment
section
[Music]
we're gonna do something a little bit
different for the comments section today
it's been a week since I did a show so
instead of reading comments from my last
episode instead I want to focus on
something that happened
um while I was away some drama
involving the daily wire in fact
and uh
kind of the elephant in the room
this is a segment of the show dedicated
to the SBG
and so it seems relevant to bring up the
fact
that there was a literal Insurrection
against the SPG while I was away on my
lengthy paternity leave
uh trying to qualify to become the next
Department of Transportation secretary
the Insurrection which by the way was
worse than January 6th at 9 11 at Pearl
Harbor and the coveted pandemic combined
times three
was launched by none other than Candace
Owens and Candace has apparently
been attempting to start her own gang
uh her own with her own fans and now
she's soliciting her audience for
suggestions in what to call
her gang so she she posted this to her
page a few days ago watch this
Matt Walsh is my arch nemesis after
daily wire and we will continue this
pursuit of trying to name my gang uh
it's definitely not going to be Cravings
please send in more suggestions guys you
got to get to the bottom of this I just
feel like you know when I retire CM I
saw him yesterday he's walking around
just super confident because he knows
he's got this sweet baby gang I'm sick
of watching him walk around like so
Jordan Peterson Lobster style because he
knows he's got this sweet baby gang
behind him disgusting we've got to end
this we need a gang name send me
suggestions
okay now first of all I didn't realize I
was Candace's arch nemesis at the
company I my wife always tells me that
I'm oblivious and not very observant of
my surroundings so I guess it's I mean
this is another example I became an arch
nemesis without even noticing it that's
fine
but now trying to supplant the SPG and I
just want to read to you some of the
suggestions that her audience is coming
up with
uh for her gang and I'm not I'm not
making this up I'm on Candace owens's
Twitter or podcast Twitter page and this
is what they're suggesting okay so and
it makes it's just conclusion too long
didn't read uh spoiler it we don't have
anything to worry about okay this the
sweet baby gang is not being taken over
so here's some of the suggestions
red candied black the hot chocolate gang
sweet candy gang the empowered pack
candies kids Candy Crushers
a lot of candy I don't as far as I know
Candace doesn't go by candy at least not
in public so I don't know where this is
coming from uh the candy O's the Candace
committee Fierce Owens Posse lit Owen's
Legion can Candace's Candy Crushers
okay now
some of these sound like names my
grandmother would come up with if she
played Fantasy Football uh some of them
sound like team names for some kind of
god-awful team building exercise at like
a Christian Youth Camp
and some of them just sound creepy
none of them hold a candle to the Sweet
Baby gang so here's the thing
Candace you can't just and I've tried to
explain this
you can't just fabricate the magic of a
sweet baby game you can't you can't
create it by committee or by pull the
sweet baby gang formed organically out
of the earth like a great
tree you know it grew from the soil and
it became this something gigantic and
formidable which will which will live
for thousands of years will outlive any
of us
it was it was it was born okay the sweet
baby gang was much like a real baby it
was conceived it was given to us by the
universe not by a Twitter poll that's
what you don't understand that's what
nobody understands
and it's why the SPG will live forever
and never be defeated
while Candy's kids will at best become
the name of like a discount daycare
center or something
in conclusion
SPG for life
this month we are celebrating the
anniversary of one of the greatest
moments in Daily wire history after
months of us leading the legal battle
against the federal government and a
national do not comply campaign the
Supreme Court ruled in our favor and
blocked the blind administration's
outrageous vaccine mandate this mandate
would have said a dangerous precedented
giving the unelected OSHA power over the
personal medical decisions of American
citizens the Supreme Court recognize
this gross power grab and they made the
right decision and we are so proud to
have led the charge in this fight but we
could not have done it without you
thousands of you joined the daily wire
and over a million Americans signed our
petition against the mandates to
celebrate we're offering 40 off our
annual memberships with the code do not
comply so celebrate one of the greatest
moments in Delaware history with 40 off
your annual membership join now at
dailywire.com subscribe and join the
winning team as we continue to crush the
left remember do not comply for 40 off
do not comply now let's get to our daily
cancellation
foreign
objection I've often encountered over my
years as a talking head and this is
something that everyone in media hears
Ad nauseam is that um you know I spend
too much time focused on the negative
why don't you ever talk about positive
things the objector asks why not spend
time discussing encouraging and
wholesome topics that's what I really
want to hear about
now the truth is that I do sometimes
talk about positive things I do in fact
spend time on my show and on other
platforms discussing more lighthearted
and happier topics on occasion at least
lighthearted and happy to me
but the people who demand such content
are nowhere to be seen once it's
provided okay they don't say hey thanks
for this it's just what I asked for
instead they say nothing because the
truth is that they've probably changed
the channel they closed out the video
because the further truth is that they
don't really want these more wholesome
themes they say they do but when they
get it they're bored
that's part of the reason why you don't
see more of the sort of cheerful and
uplifting content that so many people
pretend to want but rarely support
whenever they get it but the other
potential reason for a lack of such
content
is that
when someone in the public light shares
an encouraging thought or a happy moment
with the public
it is nearly certain that he will be
ripped to shreds by a million crazed
vultures who seek to devour happiness
like scavengers on Roadkill
uh now the point here isn't just to
whine and say what was me there's a
there's a larger point I want to make
but case in point
consider the happy moment that I
experienced and shared with the world
and have talked a little bit about on
the show late last week the day after
our Twins were born I announced the news
on Twitter and since I'm a dad of six
now I I you know I can't help but
include an extremely lame dad joke in
moments like this it's a compulsion and
also you might say a solemn
responsibility to ruin a profound moment
with a corny joke this is just it's what
we're supposed to do so I tweeted uh
kids number five and six were born last
night the males in the family now
outnumber the females five to three my
master plan is complete mom and babies
are healthy and doing well thank you for
all your prayers that's what I said
that's all I said
the totally hilarious joke about the
boys outnumbering the girls and a bit
about how I somehow planned this from
the start is a version of a joke that
approximately I don't know 700 000
people have said to me whenever they
find out that we're having two more boys
in fact it's the sort of Battle of the
Sexes type joke that families with boys
and girls make all the time amongst each
other it's all very normal
but as we've seen there is nothing that
the internet hates more than normal
which is why this tweet announcing the
birth of my children attracted hundreds
of outraged responses people outraged
so to be clear these are people who are
actively mad about a stranger announcing
the birth of his children
that emotion okay outrage over a birth
announcement is it's an emotion that
that a healthy human being has likely
never felt it's it's an emotion not even
available to a healthy person they
wouldn't know how to generate that
emotion if they wanted to
and yet many people who are
apparently capable of experiencing such
an emotion or who wish to pretend that
they experience it made their voices
heard and I'm not going to go through
and read them all
um just suffice it to say again hundreds
of people
comments sending me messages very upset
um wanting to taking time by the way
it's like I just had kids it's like to
meet so here so it takes time to lecture
me about you know the manner in which I
announce it
because I have time to really think
about that so I think this one tweet
selected at random is a fairly
representative of the whole so this was
the General tenor um a woman responded
imagine your twins being born and you
tweet that your master plan of having
more boys than girls in a family is
finally complete as the oldest of five
girls I am completely effing sick of men
celebrating male babies as inherently
more valuable very sorry for this man's
daughters
I think it's also worth singling out
this other response one other from a
woman who pretends to be a reverend uh
Reverend Kim Chaffey tweeted and
Reverend in quotes reverend in you know
Big Air quotes sir Kim Chaffey tweeted
it might be humorous where where not for
his patriarchal history and attitude
towards women not appropriate not funny
by the way um
this is a woman named Kim
who responds to a joke like that by
saying not appropriate or funny you
already have in your mind an image of
what this person looks like and it's
exactly that you're exactly right it's
that it's that person
and there are plenty more where these
came from this is to say nothing of the
people who took the time to publicly
wish that my children turn out gay or
trans that was another big response it's
quite interesting actually that those
who pretend to support gay and trans
people are also the ones most likely to
accuse you of being gay or trans as an
insult or to wish it on your children as
a curse
now for the following week I posted a
few more times about the birth each time
I was rebuked for one reason or another
and always there followed many ill
wishes to me and my family and my
newborn Sons most of this came from the
left but not all of it for instance in
response to a picture
of me simply
um sitting and holding the babies
is it uh and I don't usually post
pictures of my kids online but they're
infants and you can barely see them so
you know it's it's fine but a YouTuber
uh from the Mana sphere named Ryan Stone
tweeted
showing off the F trophies for clout
he's like the f word trophies that's
what I was so the babies are trophies
that I'm showing off for Club he then
went on a multi-tweet tirade complaining
about men who take pictures with their
own children
it's not manly apparently
to love your kids it's not and be proud
of them it's not mainly this is perhaps
not a surprise that a picture of a proud
father would be so upsetting to the sort
of man who clearly never had one
now all of this reached its tapiothus uh
uh a few days ago
when I answered a question about whether
I'd be taking a long paternity leave and
I said in reply and here I directly
quote myself
I said
um nope I'll be back to work in a couple
of days
that's what I said that was it I'll be
back to work in a couple of days end of
statement and yet even that was
offensive to some people and not a small
number so here we can use this response
as representative one man said Matt my
man I'm happy for you for real
congratulations twins a lot of work a
lot of fun good luck you do know I hope
that you could just be gracious and not
dog whistle malign people who take
paternity leave
yes to say when you're returning to work
is to dog whistle malign men on
paternity leave you can't even say when
you're coming back to work without
offending people who are not coming back
to work yet
this is ludicrous for many reasons
beginning with the fact that I don't
need a dog whistle to malign anyone if I
want to do it I'll do it openly I think
I've proved that if nothing else during
my career
now you might listen to all this and say
okay sure of course this was the
response you got it's the Internet it's
not real life that's just how people are
on the Internet besides the vast
majority of people were encouraging and
positive and congratulatory and these
trolls are in the minority and on that
latter point I agree most people have
been very supportive sending their well
wishes and prayers and for that as I
said I'm profoundly grateful
as to the former I certainly do not
agree now if many people are vicious and
vile and insane on the internet then
they are by definition vicious and vile
and insane in real life because the
Internet is real life it exists in
reality it is used by people in reality
so if you say something to somebody on
the internet you have said it to them in
real life
this idea that it's that it is it's some
sort of dream or alternate Dimension it
doesn't count
is it doesn't make sense it is a
communication device
saying the Internet isn't real life it's
like writing an insult on a piece of
paper and then handing it to someone and
then and then telling them they have no
right to be upset about it because you
didn't insult them in real life you only
insulted them on the piece of paper
relax man just a piece of paper
now it's certainly true that many of the
trolls who say heinous things on the
internet would never do it face to face
nobody would come up to me in person and
say for example I hope your newborn
children end up being trans
nobody would do that
um I'm out in public all the time and
nobody comes up to me it says anything
like that to my face
many have said it to me on the internet
never would say to my face
um that however doesn't make the
statement any less real and it also
doesn't make it any better because it
just it just makes them cowards on top
of being perverts and degenerates and
psychos
but let me get to my real point and the
real point isn't simply to just complain
about people being mean and weird on the
internet instead you know this has been
I think yet another opportunity
to learn a very valuable lesson about
the modern world
which is this that that many people hate
happiness
and this is really what lies at the root
of The Psychotic backlash that I
received for committing the sin of
talking about my children in public
I'm a family man and I'm happy in that
role and I'm proud of my family that's
why I talk about it
and that makes certain people very upset
why I mean why do people get offended by
the way why get offended by happiness
because they're deeply unhappy and
miserable themselves and they take your
happiness as a personal affront
you know the adage about Misery loving
company is true but I think it's
important to understand why it's true
that this sort of miserable selfish
person has given up on striving for
anything better in life instead they try
to attain Happiness by using this kind
of bell curve method
if they can drag everyone else down if
they can spread their misery around then
they'll have increased their own
happiness in comparison to the average
it's like if you earn more money you'll
have made yourself richer but if you
earn the same amount while everyone else
loses money you'll have closed the gap
between yourself and the richest person
thereby making yourself richer on
average
many people in our culture choose the
latter approach both metaphorically and
also literally when it comes to money
and of course not all forms of Happiness
are equally as threatening to the
miserable selfish person
in fact he'll be very encouraging to you
if you are seeking pleasure in selfish
Pursuits
or if you're doing things that are
materialistic or shallow or you know
that aren't that meaningful
and and you're happy about it and you
talk about how you're happy about it
um these sorts of people they'll be very
encouraging with that they're happy okay
because that's that's uh that is a a
non-threatening sort of happiness
that you're experiencing
but this person sort of person is
especially offended by the happiness you
derive from
good true fulfilling things from a life
of service to your family that's the
that's the most offensive kind of
Happiness to them they hate that they
really hate it
that is the kind of happiness that this
sort of person hates most of all because
he has told himself
that that sort of happiness is
impossible
he's either childless and lonely facing
the prospect of dying alone and unloved
trying to convince himself that this is
the preferable option
or he has a family but his family is
broken and poisoned by resentment and
his kids hate him and his wife left him
or whatever or husband left him if it's
a man or woman uh and just everything's
in shambles
and they're trying to convince
themselves that it's not their fault
that this is always how it ends up with
families
All Families end up this way
well your happiness
in your family life interferes with this
mental narrative
and so they will hate you for it
they're they're trying to lie to
themselves and you're getting in the way
of the LIE
and that's what lies at the root of all
of this
and it's why these pathetic miserable
wretches
not to add insult to injury you know not
that they need anymore
but they are all canceled and that'll do
it for this portion of the show as we
move over to the members block hope to
see you there if not we'll talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
foreign
[Music]